welcome to exploring computing
today's video is strings
so in this video we're going to take a
look at a closer look at how strings
work
and i want to start off with this
problem that we ran into in the last
video so you recall
i was writing to a file and i had two
write statements i wrote go stanford
and then i wrote go cardinal and instead
of
ending up with go stanford on one line
and go cardinal in the other line when
we actually opened up the file we
discovered that
go stanford and go cardinal end up on
the same line so
how am i going to fix this all right so
up on the top here we have what we ended
up with and down at the bottom we have
what we want
so if we were to represent these as
strings
this is what we would have here so up at
the top quote go stanford go cardinal
that's what we ended up with and then
the second one
goes stanford and go cardinal
what is this slash n all right that
slash n
is what we refer to as an escape
sequence and in this particular case
the slash n represents new line which
inserts a character return
now as we talked about in the very first
lecture of the quarter
there are different ways computers used
to represent the end of line
and it's different depending on whether
we're working with unix machines or
we're working with windows machines
and we have a really old old old mac
they represented a different way
and python the python interpreter is
actually going to
know the proper representation for your
specific computer and it will translate
that slash anna to the exact
sequence of ascii characters or unicode
characters
that is necessary for the particular
computer you're working on
but just so we have a general way of
doing it for any type of computer that
python is designed to work with we're
just going to represent
it with a slash n this is called an
escape sequence because
that backslash there indicates
to python that the next character that
it sees
is not to be treated normally i'm
supposed to escape the normal sequence
of
treating characters and do something
special with the next character
so don't treat that n there after the
slash as just a regular end that i print
out an n
out on the output which is what you
would normally do if you saw an n it
says no this is something different
uh there's a there's a special table of
escape sequences
look it up in the table of escape
sequences and do what it says there and
it looks it up in the table this is oh
that slash n is not a regular
n that is actually a carriage return
and so there's a couple of these so uh
probably the most common you'll run into
the slash
ends and the slash t's slash n
represents new line or carriage return
slash t represents a tab and so here
i've got the string stanford slash n t
t university and so that actually
represents
stanford followed by a new line followed
by two tabs
and if we were to actually look at the
output this is what we would see we
would see stanford on one line
university on the next line but not
university at the beginning of the line
because there are those two slash t's
representing tabs
so university tabbed over a bit
here's a couple more escape sequences
you might run into
um one question is how do you represent
a backslash
you can't just put a backslash there
because that starts the escape sequence
and so if you really want a backslash
not super common but if you really want
a backslash you have to put two
backslashes in a row
the first backslide says that's escape
character get out of the normal sequence
and the next backslash says oh uh this
particular sequence is backslash
backslash which represent a single
backslash
all right we also need one for
representing quotes so
if i wanted a quote um i would represent
that with a backslash
quote why would i want to do that well
suppose i actually want a quote in the
output so suppose i wanted the output
quote give them the axe end quote a
traditional stanford cheer
if i were to just put this in a string
this is what the string would look like
and you can see by my little not sign or
cancel sign at the end
don't do this what's going to happen
here is
i start off the string with a quote and
i end the string with a quote on the far
right after cheer
and then i place my double quotes in the
middle
and so the way this is actually going to
be interpreted by
python is it's going to see that first
pair of double quotes the initial double
quote
followed by the double quote for give
them the axe and i'll say oh
that's a little string right there and
you may recall from the last lecture we
have a string and there's no characters
in it that it's completely legal
uh and that is what we refer to as an
empty string
and then it will see the quote after the
word acts
followed by dash a traditional stanford
cheer followed by quote i'll say okay
that's a string
um because really what it's doing is
it's mashing up the pairs of double
quotes here
and that'll say but you've got these
words here give them the axe
i i don't know what that is patrick i
think this is illegal i think you need
to fix your python code
so this won't work this won't work
because
the double quotes are paired up and
because they're paired up i can't put
actual double quotes
into the string that i'm trying to
create so the way i get around this is
by the slash quote
so i say quote slash quote
or backslash quote give them the x
backslash quote
a traditional stanford cheer what's
going to happen is it's going to see
that first
double quote and it's going to see the
slash double quote
and it will see the slash first and
it'll say okay so the next character i
see which
absolutely double quote don't just treat
that like a double quote so don't treat
it as if
you know that matches with the original
double quote no that's a special
character
that is it should not be treated as a
double quote
uh character which would terminate the
string with our empty string there
that's actually oh i want to double
quote in the actual output
not as a delimiting character
delineating when the string starts and
when the string
ends so if you happen to need a double
quote into string
that's how you would do it all right
um if you want to start doing some
fancier things with strings
one of the things to be aware of is that
strengths actually work
pretty similar to lists so uh
lists and strings both act as sequences
and there are certain things that you
can do with sequences
in python and as we saw previously
in order to access individual elements
in a list we have the square bracket
notation so
in this case we have a list of team
members and i say i want to
print the second team member but you'll
recall it actually starts off numbered
at zero
so casey would be zero hank would be one
tammy would be two and so this would
actually print the word tammy
and here i've got a name
which is a string stanford and i tell it
to print
name bracket zero and so what this is
going to do
is i can access each of the individual
characters in string so
string so name 0 would be s
name 1 would be t name 2 would be a
name 3 would be n and so on so in this
case if i say print name 0 that actually
prints
the s i should caution you though in
contrast to
the elements of the list where i can
access the individual elements on the
list and not only access and get the
information out
with the list i can actually place
elements in the list we can't actually
do this with strings
so if i were to try and replace that s
with some other letter that actually is
not going to work
all right we also saw previously that we
can get the length of
a list of items and so here i am
taking the length of the course list
number of classes
and so this would like i think our
example we had three classes so this
would print
i am taking three classes and we could
do the same thing with strength so if i
say
length name where name is the strength
stanford
that would actually print the number
eight because there are eight characters
in stanford
one thing that you may have noticed when
i've been talking about
taking advantage of some of the features
built into
python you may have noticed a difference
between
different ways that we're accessing
these so you know i've told you hey
you know you can go ahead and get the
length of something you can go ahead and
print something out you can go ahead and
close the file you can go ahead and
append a file
and there is actually a difference
between how these were accessed
um some of them i just had the name of
the uh what were referred to as a
function uh
followed by a pair of parentheses
followed by whatever information we
needed so
length followed by the variable that's
storing a sequence
originally a list of items and now we
can see that
you can either pass in something
referring to a list of items or you can
pass in something to refer to string
and we'll go ahead and print out the
number of items in the string
we've definitely been doing this with
the print statement
we can print say print and then pass in
a string
or a number and it will go ahead and
print it out and in fact we saw that you
can
actually ask it to print a bunch of
things in the same line so those are
what we refer to as functions with the
functions you just have the name that
i've told you to use so
length or print or whatever followed by
the pair of parentheses
in contrast this other way of doing
things uh are is something referred to
as a method with the method we have an
existing variable
that is referring to an item followed by
a dot
followed by the name of you know this
method i've told you to use followed by
a pair of parentheses so
with with closing a file i have the name
of a variable which is referring to file
followed by a dot followed by close
filed by pair parentheses
and we also saw this with a pen so with
the pen i had the
name of a variable which was referring
to a list
followed by dot followed by a pen
followed by the item that i want to
append to that list
so i don't want to go too much into the
technical details here but i did want to
acknowledge that
that yes there are two things that look
like they're kind of doing the same
thing but they have different syntax
rules
so the main thing for our purposes is
they have
totally different ways of accessing them
i don't
say totally different but they have
different distinct clearly different
ways of accessing them so
you do need to know whether you're
working with a function or a method
and in terms of why they're different
in some cases you could do one or the
other
but what's really going on is there are
differences in how
the functions versus the methods are
used for organizing
uh programs when you're writing complex
programs whether you use one or the
other it's going to have an effect on
how your overall program's organized
and there are definitely differences in
terms of how they're implemented the
functions are easier to
write on your own in order to understand
how the methods work it's actually
fairly messy you need quite a bit of
understanding of the details of how
python works in order to properly use
the methods
all right so with that little discussion
i've got a bunch of methods i want to
talk about
um and we're going to need uh some of
these to work with files so
um bear with me here the first couple we
don't need to use for files but uh
they're pretty straightforward so i want
to start off with these
okay so the is digit method returns true
if a string is composed only of digits
so
let's say uh you know i've been reading
for files and i've been converting the
numbers by
calling int or float and converting to
the numbers
maybe we've got a file that has a bunch
of numbers mixed in with a bunch of
names and i only want to convert the
ones that are actually
numbers how would i know which one's a
number and which one isn't
well so one way you can do that is
there's an is digit
that works on strings and it returns
either true or false
um you can see our little example here
if data dot is digit
so that's our method invocation that we
saw a minute ago
name of a variable referring to string
followed by a dot
followed by the name of the method which
in this case is digit fall by a pair of
parentheses
uh whether or not that pair of
parenthesis is empty or not depends upon
the particular method we're using
um okay so if data is digit print
is a number else contains letters or
symbols
so if data were a variable storing the
string 1 2
3 4 data dot is digit would say yes
this is entirely consisting of digits so
it would go ahead and print as a number
okay is alpha is sort of the opposite
is alpha says this is going to return
true
if the string is only composed of
letters of the alphabet
so if data dot is alpha
prints all letters else print contains
numbers or symbols
and so if data is set to quote z24
this would print contains numbers or
symbols because of the two four in there
all right so here's the here's the ones
we really need um
so i mentioned this concept of white
space before
white space refers to any character that
creates blank space on the screen
so that's pretty much the spaces you
know if you have a whole bunch of spaces
that's obviously going to generate a
bunch of blank space on
on in the document if you have a bunch
of tabs that generates a bunch of
white space in the document blank space
in the document the carriage return if
you have a bunch of character turns
you're creating a bunch of blank lines
and so that's going to create a lot of
blank space in the document so again
these characters that are creating these
blank spaces we sort of group them all
together and say oh
those are characters that are generating
white space
and so these are methods that remove
white space l strip
removes white space on the left side of
the string
our strip removes white space on the
right side of the string
and then strip removes white space on
either side of the string so let's take
a look at how these will work
okay so let's say we have this uh string
here stored in the variable original
where we've got a bunch of spaces
followed by stanford spoiled by
a slash n followed by slash t so that
slash n that's my
new line character the slash t that's
the tab
and so both the spaces and the slash and
on the slash t
that's all white space so if i
create a new variable called data and i
say what i want to store in data
is the original string and then called
the
message strip on it that it's going to
remove
white space from both sides so it'll
remove the spaces at the beginning of
the string it will remove the slash and
the t at the end of the string
and so when we're done with this the
variable data will store the string
quote stanford end quote without the
spaces without the slants
and without the slash t those will all
go away
now uh if you want to i think it's less
common to need to
strip the white space from just one of
the sides but if you wanted to if we
were to do
for example r strip this strips off the
white space on the right side of string
which in this case is the slash and the
slash t
but it leaves the white space on the
left side of the string so in this
particular case
data would be set to quote space space
stanford because
the white space on the left side of
string is left and only the white space
on the right side of the string is
removed
all right so uh why do i want to do this
why do i care about this
all right so it turns out that when i'm
reading strings
from a file uh it's actually going to
leave the new lines at the end of each
character i've alluded to this a little
bit earlier
so here i'm reading a bunch of names
from a file
and storing them in a list
if my list contains the following names
patrick molly craig tammy and chloe the
actual list that i'm going to end up
with says
quote patrick slash n quote
molly slash n slash craig slash n and so
on so
um you know we've we've talked before
about how
that end of the line is actually
represented by an actual
you know bit sequence uh whether we're
using ascii or unicode or whatever our
character encoding is
there is a bit sequence associated with
the end of the line and so what we're
seeing here is that
python is going ahead and just copying
those over and saying hey there's a
character at the end line i'm just going
to go ahead and put it in your uh
you know when you read the line i'm
going to go ahead and not only include
the visible characters i'm also going to
include that
invisible end of line character
you may also notice that this
list down at the bottom that python has
given us
is marking its strings with single
quotes instead of double quotes
so it turns out that in python you can
represent strings either with single
quotes or you can represent with double
quotes i've been using double quotes
because most programming languages
use double quotes so if you were to
continue on studying computer science
and you were used to having single
quotes for your strings
that would be a bad habit to get into
however
uh while python is perfectly happy to
accept double quotes when we're writing
our code or when you're interacting with
the python shell
in fact when it spits the strings back
to you it always uses the single quotes
i'm not quite sure why they did it but
um anyway so you will see those single
quoted strings
when you're working with the python
shell um
you know you can use single quote
strings if you want but again i think
it's a bad habit to get into because
most languages uh require you to use
double quotes all right so
you know probably i don't want all those
slash ends at the end of each of these
names it seems kind of
annoying i don't know about you but if i
have a kid i'm not
naming it with a slash and at the end of
their name maddie does not have a slash
n at the name of her end of her name
um okay so how am i going to get rid of
it
well here's a new version of the
code that's going to read it's going to
read the names from our file
and you can see what i've done here is
i've just added name dot r strip so what
this is going to do is this is going to
read this in the individual names so
i've got a little for loop
name and data file and so name is going
to be set to each of the
lines of text from our data file here or
our names file here
and what we're going to do is we're
going to strip off
any of the extra white space
on the right side before i start into my
name list before i append it onto the
end of my name list
so in this case those slash ends which
occur at the end of each line
that's just going to get stripped off by
the r strip and so you can see i
end up with a list that i want which is
the list of the names from the file
without the slash
ends on the end all right that's it for
now i'll talk to you all soon
you